ONE WILDCARD SPOT. THE
GAME.
GEARING UP THE LEAD, AS YOU
WOULD EXPECT.
HAVE NOT PLAYED HERE IN A
COUPLE OF SEASONS.
WITH THE WITTY FORMAT
THEY HAVE GOT Y SCORING CHANCES
HE GOT HIS OWN REBOUND.
GOOD FEET, CARRY IT, GOT PUCK .
BOUCHARD.. DAVID
LOOKS ACROSS TO THE HIGH SLOT.
DRAISAITL SCORES.
A GREAT READ FROM RYAN
HE JUST WANTED WIDE WAS KANE.
HE HAD A LITTLE TIME AND BOX CO!
>> Willy: ANOTHER CENTER PAST
CLEARED AWAY.IS UP, HIS
HEAD IS MOVIVI. THEY HAD THE ED
THE FIRST QUARTER, NOT ONLY ON
THE SCOREBOARD, BUT JOSI  THAT
IT DOWN.
THAT ALLOWS SAROS A DOUBLE PUSH
TO THE POST.  , IT IS
FRONT.
THERE IS NO WAY.
SAROS HAS NO IDEA WHERE THIS
PUCKCKCOMES TO KNOW.
KANE, A CENTERING PASS, SCORE!
TO GET  BACK.
AND THEN NURSE JUST
FROM THE 4 ON 4 TO A
TRIES FOR THE MAN OUT.
GET CUT ON THE FAR SIDE.
HE HAD SMITH DOWN AND OUT WITH
HIS
>> Willy: IT IS
BEHIND SMITH LEG.
SISSONS COMES IN JAMS OF THIS IN
. THERE MIGHT BE A CHALLENGE  S
THEY ARE PUTTING THE HEADSET
COMING INTO TONIGHT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CLOSE THAT
GAPCHANCE IN FRONT OF
THE NET.
THIS ONE RIGHT HERE
LEON DRAISAITL PUTTING ON A
CLINIC HERE IN S UP THAT FAR SI
>> Willy: THIS IS NASHVILLE'S E
BOX, HE SETS UP A LIEN RIGHT
.
EKHOLM, REBOUND, SET TO THE
CORNER.
BACK TO ECUTE THEM
AND GET THEM TO GO RIGHT HERE.
LOOK AT THIS.